should I make the case that this
character actually might be riots worse
agent on release not every agent in
valorant is created equally some are
broken on release whereas others just
take time to find their place within the
meta but every once in a while an
absolute trash heap of an agent comes
out and players think they are just
terrible and Riot's latest blunder is
none other than deadlock she's really
inefficient to play on attack she's not
really a sentinel you think that look
who you picked absolutely
bad but is deadlock really the worst
agent in the game and more importantly
is she actually a symptom of a bigger
issue
laughs
[Applause]
all right so before we talk deadlock and
balance agent design I must humbly
request that you please like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications
I promise it really helps alright so
back in June Riot revealed valorent's
23rd agent deadlock at Masters Tokyo
classified as a sentinel deadlock was
poised to shake up a meta that was
mostly dominated by killjoy all year but
Riot didn't want her to feel like just
your average everyday Sentinel a lot of
our Sentinels require a lot of setup you
know you've got your like small window
before the round starts where you're
like running around your area setting
everything up and be like super
stressful anxiety ridden and then no one
shows up on your site no one shows up on
your location you get like a little sad
and you're like all right let me take
down my stuff let me move on over here
um and so we wanted to create a sentinel
that is more about reacting to the
situation at hand how do you stall on
the Fly how do you prepare yourself in a
certain position to be able to take
advantage of enemies that are slowed
down in some way and initially deadlock
looked promising when Ryan released
gameplay footage of her later that month
it was obvious that they'd achieved what
they'd set out to do Deadlock's kit was
definitely unique she had sensors that
were triggered by Audio and could
concuss enemies while her signature
ability was a wall that blocked players
from moving through it she also had a
grenade that forced players to crouch
which in turn slowed them down so far so
good right but it was her alt
Annihilation that really stood out it
was a pulse of nanowires that could
bounce off walls and capture the first
enemy it hit putting them in a cocoon
and pulling them back to the point of
origin if your teammates didn't free you
before you reached the end you would die
and once everyone all saw that they lost
their [__] minds what what the [__]
is this he's turning into a tornado
fully cocooned that player will be
instantly killed if they get pulled to
the end so you're telling me I can just
get a free kill everything around I'm
playing with agent every single game if
you're not would be one you just to win
but as more players got their hands on
the agent and some of the hype started
to die down everyone realized that
deadlock might not have been as good as
they initially thought should I make the
case that this character as she might be
riots worse agent on release I don't
know how you can make it work with her
being your only Sentinel it feels like
she's really bad at holding the flank if
I play against one I just walk Flank In
the entire game I feel like this no
other piece of utility that does less
than this grenade because the grenade
what it does it literally makes people
Crouch that's it
Deadlock's wall is decent at locking
down areas and Pistol rounds and can be
an asset on the defensive side but aside
from that it can be difficult to find
Value in using it her wall lacks the
versatility of something like a sage
wall which at least allows you to stand
on top of it and make a unique plays
with its verticality Deadlock's gravnet
can occasionally be useful when comboed
with other utility but by itself forcing
players to crouch isn't all that great
and it's pretty easy to dodge too but
worst of all are her Sonic sensors since
they're only triggered by Audio you
can't just throw them onto walls and
expect to gain info players can simply
walk past undetected if you're not
watching and even if the sensors do get
triggered any half decent player with
good enough reaction time will shoot
them before they get stunned and if for
some reason they do get stunned it isn't
really that big of a deal we've all seen
what pros and players with Crispy aim
can do while can cussed
one enemy remaining
at the time of writing this Deadlock's
pick rate in matchmaking is only 2.1 and
her win rate is 48.8 percent according
to valorant tracker and some of you are
probably wondering if any of that
actually matters agents can be plenty
good and just not get picked and ranked
since people just want to lock in in
Reina and jet and run it down but
valorant Champions just ended and we
went to the entire tournament without
seeing a single deadlock You could argue
that since deadlock has only been out
for a few months maybe teams just aren't
willing to risk trying to incorporate
her into their comps before the biggest
event of the year but it's not exactly
abnormal to see an underdog team try to
catch their opponents off guard with a
pocket pick even when yoru was widely
considered one of the worst agents in
the game he saw a play on the
international stage but with deadlock
Pros seem to think that she's literally
unplayable for the entire season I was
with NRG right and set and the whole
core they're known for the cookage you
know what I mean they they be cooking
Gekko came out joru all this stuff right
we experimented with all these agents
the one agent we never even thought
about touching was deadlock we didn't
even there wasn't even even a discussion
about it the doctors can't compete with
the other agents in The Meta right now
it just it really can't yo you have
flashes you have deception it adds this
adds another layer to your game gecko
allows you to play a different type of
play style where you are playing with
more guns out like paper x what is
deadlock gonna do on T side now when
Ryan announced deadlock they made it
very clear that they wanted her to field
different from the other Sentinels the
problem is that she just can't fulfill
her role on the attacking side except
what exactly is that role like what are
Sentinels supposed to do on Attack well
as it happens our good buddy Colton
would love nothing more than to walk us
step by step through the various guiding
philosophies of valorence agent rolls
isn't that right Colton and now the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about Valor and agents have roles
okay okay I do at least know that much
and while I don't know a ton about Valor
and agents Nile's actually the one who
wrote this so in this instance he's the
guy who knows what he's talking about
according to Riot Sentinels are
defensive experts who can lock down
areas and watch flanks both on attacker
and Defender rounds but deadlock can't
reliably watch flanks and prevent pushes
the same way that Cipher or killjoy can
with their trip wires and other utility
it's pretty common for agents who share
the same role to have similar utility
but usually they have somewhere that
they specifically Excel but deadlock
just doesn't at this point it's pretty
obvious that she either needs some
pretty serious Buffs or a whole ass
rework to even be a useful agent
basically everything in her kids needs
to be better wall needs to be more
consistent more flexible and just be
easier to throw down and just
consistently know for a fact that when
you throw it it's gonna land and block
officer and choke gravnet last longer
Sonic sensor either go off instantly or
just not off sound just off-site
deadlock is the worst agent to ever be
released like it's the first agent that
I couldn't even like try to lie to my
viewers and be like hey well maybe
you're just playing it wrong you know
what I mean like I was able to say it
with Gekko I was able to stay with your
room and be like hey well maybe you guys
are just approaching it the wrong way no
deadlock is just
fresh valrant has seen its fair share of
weak agents over the past few years but
none of them really come even close to
being this bad but all hope isn't lost
for deadlock Riot still has plenty of
opportunities to fix her they've already
made changes to a bunch of agents to
kick off the VCT offseason and with a
new duelist planned for release later
this year there's no doubt that we'll
see at least some shift in The Meta if
it's one thing that Riot loves it's
shaking things up which isn't
necessarily a bad thing in this case
they've been pretty good at listening to
the community so far and who knows maybe
they're already working on some changes
that would bring deadlock back into the
fold so let's do a little Theory
crafting you valorum players what
changes would you actually want to see
made to deadlock I'm always in the
comments so let me know and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about okay so it's relatively obvious
that deadlock still hasn't found her way
but why should we care so much about
bringing her into the meta well I think
a lot of players are just bored heard of
seeing killjoy in nearly every single
agent cop The Sentinel meta as a whole
has become pretty stale sure you see the
occasional Cipher but even Sage Israeli
played we are at a critical moment for
this game valorant's biggest competitor
is about to release a long anticipated
Sequel and three years in the game needs
new and creative ideas now more than
ever ride has continuously shown that
they want valorent to differentiate
itself from Counter-Strike so they
release these unique agents who don't
just have your standard flashes smokes
or molotovs but by the virtue of being
different this approach also has created
a problem that has plagued the game
since its release simply put sometimes
riot
overcooks
Wild
someone cooked here still Valor needs
new things to keep the game fresh even
if it takes a while to balance and
massage these unique characters into
well-rounded agents that can be a part
of the future
I definitely really really really really
really really really really really
really hate a chamber I wasn't playing
ranked anymore like I had long stop
playing right I was only playing
unranked and if they picked chamber in
unranked I would just dodge the lobby I
just like genuinely had no desire I I'm
not I'm not gonna die to some wannabe
bronze Kenny s it's just so cringe